welcome back a Fox News Alert only nine
states in the u.s. will peak in copa90
Neth s-- by the end of april that
according to a new model from the
University of Texas so what does this
shocking data mean as the country tries
to reopen here with his expert insight
Fox News medical contributor dr. Marty
Macari dr. Meharry we're already talking
about reopening the country but this new
model shows that a majority of states
are gonna really reach their peak over
the summer so what do you think about
that timeline well it's very interesting
Carly
you know this model from the University
of Texas at Austin looked at cellphone
data to actually figure out whether or
not people were practicing true social
distancing and using that information
they tried to calculate when the peak is
going to be coming around now it's
interesting even though the country
engaged in different official government
policies at different times the peak has
been relatively harmonious that is we've
not seen the staggering of peaks over
the course of two months as the model
separate death predicted we've seen
things that at least the increase in
hospitalizations the increase in ICU
stays in the ink and the increase in
deaths arrests relatively around the
same time nationally and so it's
interesting to see whether or not this
model that predicts early peaking in
seven different states turns out to be
true or not yeah and if that's not
troubling enough we also have this
concern about immunity and people that
have already had it let's listen to dr.
deborah birx we know that when you get
sick and you recover and you develop
antibody that that antibody is often
confers immunity we just don't know if
it's as immunity for a month immunity
for six months immunity for six years so
doctor I mean if you're immune if you
get it in you're only immune for a
couple months what does that mean well
it could mean there's susceptibility in
the fall when we all expect a second
wave now I say that not to create panic
but when what we do sees cases in
September we don't
create to create hysteria this may be
expected that maybe that we get this
manageable to a point where it's more
like the seasonal flu but remember those
antibodies we don't know what they mean
and so we've got to remember that
immunity just means at the time that
you're tested yeah you know I think when
people hear that a majority of states
are gonna peak some time in you know
June that scares a lot of folks but then
we also have to recognize the fact that
we are sort of already seeing a national
flattening of the curve and a lot of
Governors are saying that we are not
going to experience the peak that they
anticipated in their states so how do
you kind of square this study away with
what we're actually seeing on the ground
in individual states well remember an
early on Carly we thought that a peak
meant a massive spike at one moment and
while that was the case in New York and
maybe in Louisiana what we have seen is
as people got aware as the word got out
as we've heard from the White House
early on about even the initial 15-day
measure that people started to take the
right precautions they started to do
social distancing regardless of what
their governor said and what we've seen
is most of the country has started a
plateau around the same time which is
this week this is the peak this is
probably the week and maybe the
following week from from this week that
is probably going to represent the peak
and what we're going to see is a
plateauing where yes the maximum number
of cases technically might be a little
bit down the road but we're starting to
see that plateau around the country and
our concern is how long is that going to
go on for and can we get lucky and have
this virus mutated to a safer form or
can we come up with a therapeutic in the
meantime or can the distancing stop the
transmission from person to person so
that we reduce the burden in society to
make it manageable yeah that's right you
don't want that plateau to last for a
week you really want to see that dip
doctor Meharry thank you so much for
breaking it down for us we appreciate it
thank you thank you doctor